marie pierre martin bonjour bonjour
merci d'avoir accepté notre invitation
ce matin sur rtl france alors on vous
parlait de la situation en bretagne de
cette commune de l'île aux moines qui
n'a plus de médecin aujourd'hui à cause
de la position du pass and iter est ce
que c'est un cas que vous voyez vous
aussi autour de vous ces derniers jours
en fait c'est compliqué le l'hôpital
sous d'un sous-effectif chronique depuis
plusieurs
décennies maintenant depuis une
situation qu'on dénonce depuis ces deux
dernières années avec le collectif est
aujourd'hui en fait ce qu'on redoute s
réalise ça veut dire que on n'a pas les
moyens de se permettre de se passer de
personnel soignant actuellement quand on
a des équipes qui sont cons des
mutations qui sont bloqués quand on a
des équipes ou les collègues s'en vont
en masse on n'a pas les moyens de se
passer ne serait-ce que dix ans de
patients en deux collègues parents et
c'est vraiment ce qu'on redoutait c'est
vraiment ce qu'on voulait pas voir
arriver et maintenant c'est la
maintenance et la le l'exécutif se
réunit mercredi en conseil de défense
pour desserrer l'étau sur le passage de
terre a priori est ce que vous attendez
quelque chose de cette réunion un
assouplissement de cette obligation
vaccinale
l'assouplissement l'aide l'obligation
vaccinale ou pas de toute façon ce sera
décidé peu importe commence on se
positionne dessus la réalité c'est que
aujourd'hui dans le secteur du soin on
appuie 80% des soignants qui sont
vaccinées dans le secteur public on est
appelés 81 10 % donc c'est déjà énorme
et c'est pas ça qui va régler le
problème de l'hôpital public ces besoins
qui va faire qu'on va réussir à prendre
en charge nos patientes de manière
correcte et de manière décente et en
fait on a plutôt besoin de deux
personnes qui nous écoutent et qui est
qui qui réalise les soins qu'on a depuis
plusieurs plusieurs années maintenant
c'est pas des caprices ont fait pas ça
pour
me rendre intéressant c'est vraiment des
besoins qu'on a nos patients en fait et
on a vraiment besoin que l'on soit
écoutée est ce que ces besoins il
faudrait qu'il soit traité au niveau
local est ce que faudrait que la
question soit régionaliser selon vous
encore une fois c'est pendant des années
on nous a expliqué que c'étaient des
problèmes d'organisation local qu'on
avait à l'hôpital que c'est pour ça que
ça marchait pas et en fait on s'est
rendu compte que les problèmes étaient
nationaux on a besoin d'une vraie
transformation du système de santé que
ce soit au niveau au niveau national et
pour tout le monde parce que là on ne
s'en sort pas en fait personne ne s'en
sort qu'est ce que vous pensez d'un
assouplissement du du pas salutaire dans
certains départements ça devrait se
décider au niveau des départements est
ce qu'il ya des hôpitaux qui sont moins
sous tension en fonction des
départements
il ya des hôpitaux qu'il ya des
départements qui sont mon intention
après décidé d'un vaste sanitaire
départemental encore une fois nous on
n'est pas moi je suis pas
épidémiologistes pour dire si c'est si
c'est utile ou pas moi je sais ce que je
vois au quotidien je sais ce dont on a
besoin au quotidien on est on est dedans
on note sur le terrain on a les deux
mains dedans et en fait on essaye
d'avancer comme on peut nous on a des
collègues qui sont suspendre aujourd'hui
il ya deux ans il était envoyé en ré à
100 sans rien sans masque et aujourd'hui
on leur dit que s'ils sont pas vaccinés
c'est de leur faute que les patients
sont bac sont contaminés c'est un peu
c'est un peu léger c'est faire porter le
chapeau aux soignants d'un échec
vaccinale c'est vraiment voir le
déplacer le problème en fait on
on préfère fustiger les soignants qui se
soigne qui se vaccinent pas plutôt de
comprendre déjà pourquoi est-ce qu'ils
axim pas dans un premier temps et
ensuite de réaliser que c'est pas parce
qu'il ya 5 % des soignants qui se
vaccinent pas que on va réussir à ne pas
ralentir le virus c'est pas à cause
d'eux que le virus continue d'avancer ou
pas merci beaucoup marc et pierre martin
d'avoir accepté notre invitation
ce matin sur rtl france